if you see Andy will you not tell him
I'm here okay because of what happened I
don't want him to think stop don't want
to know the less I know about other
people's Affairs the happier I am I'm
not interested in caring about people
I once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend I ever had
we still never talk sometimes
this came out
huh I am starving I haven't had lunch
since yesterday so I'm gonna head over
to Callahan's oh no no don't go there
they totally skimp on pickles let me go
to big head Joe's for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food trust me they have one
that's called the meat tornado
literally killed the guy last year
you had me at me tornado
was a six round pick Kali was the fourth
round Indianapolis Colts know how to
draft so well they really do Andy this
was delicious it's awesome huh it's a
whole new meat delivery system
thank you son what do you say we go out
to the parking lot run a few pass plays
to burn off the calories you are an
Unstoppable good idea machine
I like Andy
I'm surrounded by a lot of women in this
department
and that includes the men
up
close corner
and he made up libertarianism is all
about individual liberty and it should
never be defined by the terms liberal or
conservative and communism is no good
that's right big swing and a miss yeah
and what's the word for when a few
clerics are in charge
religious oligarchy holy
I can remember things I guess hmm
and keep mine rare a man after my own
heart
Ron
last name done
is that your name or are you telling me
you're finished talking both
done and done
I like Ron
Now That's What I Call shooting is this
a hunting game yeah it's fine you want
to play indeed I do
if you'd like I could offer you some
pointers
hunting Donna is about silence balance
and patience
get ready
the deer right
yeah it's a gather something
hunting
No Quarters required
hang on
a license to hunt at night
I thought you were serious come on now
you know I don't give a
fresh air
real weapons and honest kill
there is no substitute for the real
thing
you want to go back and play that video
game don't you yes damn it
come on come on come on that's what I
call shooting and that's a
you finally made it in the top ten now
you can enter your initials my initials
are private well then just put in any
three letters
ass
would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
I think I can give you any more
I love food and stuff
it's where I buy all of my food
and most of my stuff
hey can I get these
how much are they
two bucks a piece
good deal
anything else nope just the crows and
the beef
you beanbag come with me I'm an eggplant
I don't care come with me why I need
small hands
I'm
scared
there I think I got it yep you got it
can you at least tell me what you're
doing
I'm a homeowner I would like to actually
learn something
yeah I'm tightening the valve stem into
the valve shank I'm replacing the handle
and then tightening the set screw which
will hold it in place now
oh my God
it's a good feeling
sense of accomplishment and pride
damn it I just love it so much
are you okay
great I'm gonna go around this house and
fix everything I can find that needs
fixing you want to help I really do
good
that's next
excuse us
ah nice form son make sure you keep a
firm pressure on the cranium on the
cranium listen up I have to turn off the
power for one minute we're gonna go dark
people bear with us okay we gotta switch
off the main fuse hose it's just a fuse
it's just a fuse people just a fuse
I'd say you got the handle on that
torque wrench
is a little warped so I just goosed it
with the triple three bolts Mac that was
nonsense I know
no you know what
keep this
you earned it
thanks Ron
Donna this is crazy typhoon is an artist
and the human head is canvas just listen
you're gonna cut the man's hair you're
gonna charge him eight dollars it'll
take you four minutes so just shut up
and make the man look like this
fine
so typhoon
what do you like to do for fun I'm
writing an electronic Opera about
Brittany Murphy and I do the chandelier
design for my friend's drag puppet show
no further questions all I really want
to do is dance except lately all the
good Warehouse Raves are filled with
Euro trash
Euro trash I like that it is indeed a
garbage continent yes oh my God I had
the worst time in Berlin last May
everyone was on their stupid bikes that
was like ew
please talk more about how you hate
Europe and bicycles
you know you are a wonderful guy and I
admire many things about you but you're
a terrible person to discuss personal
problems with thank you friend
that really means a lot to me